what are good and effective ways to
collect information on a company so from
my time working as a consultant and
later as a project lead at mckinsey i
want to share my insights my tips and
tricks on exactly this topic of company
research which i hope will be helpful
for many of you as well these techniques
will prove very helpful if you're
currently preparing for job interviews
or maybe already signed a labor contract
and not preparing for the first days
weeks or months and your new employer
these infos will also be relevant if
you're a consultant who wants to prepare
for a new project for a new client and
wants to get up to speed with this new
company in a faster way so welcome to
another coffee break here on my channel
firm learning my name is heiner here on
my channel i want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career so with no further ado let's get
into it and today i want to share with
you four tips what you can do to do some
company research and all these tips have
in common that first you can do them
from home second you don't need any
access to any database so it's pretty
much for free and third it's very easy
and straightforward to do that so also
no significant time investment required
and stick until the end because
especially the last two i think are
quite juicy and important so make sure
you're not missing them and the first
step is to read the news on the company
and while this might seem a little bit
obvious you would be surprised how many
people i talk to also i worked with who
were not even aware about the last news
publications about the client for
instance that we just started working
for and now to go a bit beyond the
obvious let me share two specific to it
that you can use to really simplify and
facilitate this news research the first
tool is the google news platform so this
is a search machine from google
specifically dedicated to news so if
you're typing in the name of your
company here you will likely find much
better results regarding the news than
if you just type in the company name in
the overall google search bar because
here all search articles that you get on
news articles indeed the second is
google alerts and this is pretty cool
because here you can define a search
term and whenever there's a new search
result on google popping up for the term
you will get an alert for instance an
email that google sends you with the
overview of all the new articles that
came out and here you can also tailor
this to decide whether you want to have
this really live whenever something new
comes in or whether you want to have a
collection of results once a day or once
per week depending on how common your
search term is you might want to go for
the one or the other but this is really
something i would recommend you to do
also for your current employer or maybe
also your current client project that
you are doing make sure that you have a
google alert activated and this can also
be pretty cool for your team so imagine
you are a consultant your partner has a
meeting with a board member later that
afternoon and you have the google alert
activated and get the news that there's
a new article that was released in the
local press of where the company is from
here it can be a pretty cool move to be
the one who first knows about this
shares the article with the team with
the partner and then helping the partner
to have a great meeting with the board
member because now the partner has an
icebreaker and maybe the article is even
about a difficult topic a difficult
situation that the company is facing you
for sure it would be important for your
senior leadership for your partners to
be aware of what's currently going on at
the client and this can be a little
piece of enabling that next tip is to
read the annual report of that company
so if you're not a rare annual report
there's a report that every publicly
traded company needs to release once per
year at least in most countries where
they give an overview about their
business activities their financials
their strategy it's really super
insightful in a great source of
information you can usually find annual
reports in the investor relations
section of the company's website or if
you just google annual report plus the
company name usually will directly pop
up information that's typically included
in these reports are information on the
overall company strategy some key
business results that were achieved
future focus initiatives what the
company wants to accomplish in the
future and report on industry trends and
business risks that the company is
facing information on personnel and also
remuneration of these people and also
basic financials such as profit and loss
statement cash flow statement balance
sheet and often also all types of other
performer ratios these reports are
usually extremely detailed and really a
great source of information also with
infos on competitors on overarching
industry trends so definitely something
that can inspire many other types of
analysis that you also do next is a tip
which is maybe the most insightful one
and can give you access to information
which is not that easily found for
instance i'm just googling certain
things but before we dig into this let
me introduce you to the sponsor of this
week's video data camp datacamp is an
online learning platform where you can
improve your data analysis skills you
know that this is something i talk about
all the time this is really a crucial
part of your skill set if you want to
succeed in any consulting role and i
trust in many roads in industry and for
sure in banking as well with datacam
there are no previous data skills needed
to get started you can learn from things
as basic as xl101 to more advanced
technical things like for instance
database manipulation and sql so for
sure if the things that i show you here
in this video are over your head you
really have no idea what this is all
about there are some also very
introductory courses on excel in data
camp which i trust can help you they
have over 300 courses with interactive
learning and you can also learn on the
go with the mobile app that they have
personally i very much liked the
introduction to sql course which already
helped me several times on my own
projects when i needed to interact with
databases so give it a try and i trust
that working with data camp indeed can
fast track your data analysis skills and
these for sure are so crucial in any
consulting role but also many other
related roads as well so if this peaked
your interest and you would like to try
out datacam then invest in yourself
check out datacam via the link in the
video description and you will get
access to the first chapter of every
single course for free but let's
continue and as i said the next tip i
find especially insightful and this is
leveraging local business registers
because while annual reports are great
they're often only available really for
the largest publicly traded publicly
listed companies but even for the
smaller ones many of them need to
release business information on a
regular basis
and this is exactly what you can get
access on on these local business
registers these registers will have
different names in different countries
in germany for instance it's the
bundesan saga usually if you just type
company register and then your country
into google you will likely find the
name of the company register of your
country and then can search for it in a
similar way similar to annual reports
these company registers often contain
information on financials they often
contain the last audit reports they
might contain information on the
ownership structure on the management
team and on employee figures often this
information is less detailed than in the
annual reports and the width of
information that needs to be released
often depends on the company's size so
you often have different levels of
detail available depending on which type
of company exactly you're looking up and
what makes these registers even more
powerful is that nowadays there are all
types of meta registers all types of
meta search machines that have
connections to several of these local
country registers and then combine all
the information so for the eu for europe
it's for instance north data.com here
you can just type in the name of a
person or type in the name of a company
and you get all types of information
also from different countries here so if
you're ever interested for instance in
the business activity of any of your
family members or relatives or friends
you can just type in the name of that
person into for instance not data.com
and you see all the companies they're
affiliated to whether they're managing
director or in similar positions this is
all the information that you will have
so just for demonstration purposes
probably most of you will know the
youtuber ali abdal al if you're watching
this love your content great channel so
if you just try out typing his name into
north data you see now all the companies
that he has founded just head up his
businesses but of course you can also do
this with actual companies so for
instance you could type in siemens and
then really get access to a plethora of
information that i trust really really
help you to understand what exactly
happened with this organization in the
past what was going on and do some
research based on that last but not
least let's talk about the importance of
researching industry trends so here i
trust it's not even that difficult to do
that you can just type the industry of
interest plus industry trends in the
google search bar and they get all types
of reports as stated earlier you can
also use annual reports to really get
this information read what the company
themselves are writing about this so i
rather want to talk about why this is so
great and why this is so important and
from my experience researching industry
trends are great icebreakers in
conversations with clients so for
instance in the construction industry
which is the industry that i currently
work in there's at the moment a huge
shortage of wood so let's imagine you're
a consultant are working for
construction company so in one of the
first meetings with your clients you
could ask them you know there's this
huge shortage in wood how is this
affecting your company at the moment
what does this mean to you this can
really be a great icebreaker for your
conversation and the best thing is that
things like this also portray you as
knowledgeable if you openly talk about
industry trends like this surely you
know something about the industry surely
you're more than just a young graduate
fresh out of university who has no clue
what he or she is doing right so these
are the little tricks that have you in
conversations with clients researching
the industry being able to share little
bits and pieces like this can really
make the difference in how you are
perceived by your clients that are able
to build client relationships but now
let me hear from you what is your advice
on how to do company research in a
straightforward way trust your insights
will help not only be but everyone else
in the firm learning community as well
so please leave a comment with your
insights in the comment section as
always if you took any value out of this
video at all please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe to this channel and turn on
notifications to stay up to date on all
my content i once again want to give a
shout out to the sponsor of this week's
video data camp if you're interested in
data camp check out the link to them in
the video description and of course also
big thanks to all the members of firm
learning for your support if you want to
hear even more from me i'm also present
on linkedin twitch instagram and tick
tock links to all of them in the video
description i'm heinrich i'm releasing
new videos every single saturday here on
firm learning looking forward to seeing
you again next week until then bye bye